bonsoir Paris ici Cannes c'est à VOUS
dérouler le tapis rouge à la 76e édition
du plus grand festival de cinéma du
monde et peu importe le vent la pluie le
nuages qui nous menace on sera là à
partir de 20h avec du public ils seront
là nombreux l'ange gardien écrit une
lettre pour expliquer pourquoi elle
refusait de jouer de faire lol qui
resort sur Amazon que j'avais fait et
Adele a écrit une lettre pour expliquer
qu'elle arrêtait le cinéma et qu'elle
condamnait le Festival de Cannes ou je
sais où vous serez dans quelques heures
véritable star du 7e art Sophie Marceau
émotion prendre sa plume et vient de
sortir un recueil de poèmes consacré au
désir féminin en pleine promo de son
ouvrage l'actrice a accordé une
interview au journal Libération où elle
s'est confiée sur ses propres désirs si
en matière d'amour chacun ses propres
préférences la femme de 56 ans a de son
côté révélé être sapiosexuel en clair la
beauté d'un homme l’intéresse peu elle
est attirée par l'intelligence et par le
savoir une déclaration étonnante qui a
surpris de nombreux fans de l'actrice
moi bon bah oui je vais à Cannes je vais
porter des robes sur un tapis rouge
c'est pas le programme le plus super
choquant pour une actrice mais est-ce
que c'est avec moi qu'on va faire la
révolution non pas sûr et peut-être
qu'on en a besoin
que ce film vous en avez eu l'idée ici à
Cannes il y a ou presque il y a 17 ans
la première fois que vous êtes venus sur
la Croisette
à Paris dans une salle normale et il
était en compétition à Cannes oui
d'accord allez tout ramener à Cannes
oui c'est un idéal pour moi aussi
d'accorder quand même ces valeurs à une
manière de vivre alors j'essaye de le
faire mais c'est plus faible qu'elle
c'est plus faiblarde
c'est bien je te laisse
[Musique]
salut
je la connaissais parce que en fait
quand elle était mise et transport et
elle a commencé à me suivre sur facebook
et en plus de ça ben on savait qu'il y
avait quelqu'un qui s'appelle Elisabeth
vin qui travaillait dans le gouvernement
on n'a pas le même âge on a pas la même
tête du coup je pense que c'est vraiment
très facile de faire la différence entre
les deux est-ce que vous savez ce qui se
passe en ce moment à Reykjavik en
Islande
Macron
parce que j'avoue je me suis un peu
déconnecté là en histoire
[Musique]
et oui il se passe des choses en dehors
de Cannes une fois l'allocution du
Président de la République terminée
Jimmy Nicolas et Julien sortent
manifester il part de la gare et ensuite
on est parti majusculeur on a mis
quelques poubelles il y a le neveu de
Brigitte qui a poussé quelqu'un sur une
poubelle voilà qui a poussé quelque
chose on l'a défendu c'est à ce
moment-là que plusieurs personnes
auraient roué de coups Jean-Baptiste
trogneux je prends les fêtes elles sont
c'est un mec qui sait faire agresser par
cette connard tous plus éclectiques les
uns que les autres on a un mec de 35 ans
qui traîne avec des mecs de 20 ans bon
je pose la question hein c'est jamais tu
as une gamine elle est même pas majeur
on se demande quel foulard et puis tu as
le reste des desituants quand ils
parlent ils sont bas de plafond c'est
obligatoire il y a juste des poubelles
des poubelles posées il y a eu juste un
sac lancée
c'est tout simplement ça c'est quand
après c'est Jean-Baptiste tronic il est
sorti car clairement m'a plaqué mon mon
collègue à terre et moi j'ai juste
attrapé la personne qui l'a qui lui a
roule le coup je l'ai attrapé par
derrière je l'ai ceinturer pour dégager
quoi Jimmy lui assume ce qu'il s'est
passé c'est vraiment bien sûr légère non
c'est pas parce que c'est le neveu de
Brigitte à il faut le défendre non à un
moment là c'est bon on vit dans une
drôle de France à un moment donné il
faut se réveiller on peut pas rester
comme ça surtout avec un président qui
nous écoute pas c'est des mecs je suis
persuadé ils ont pas travaillé un [__]
de trimestre dans leur année s'il te
plaît et ça vient ouais mais Macron les
stress machin m'a arrêté arrêtez 2
secondes c'est c'est cette abruti
congénitaux qui ont décidé de s'en
prendre à un mec tout seul voilà ça ce
que c'est ce que je retiens cette
contrainte ça va tranquille on est bien
en attendant l'arrivée du père les
gendarmes sont contraintes de supporter
des histoires du jeune homme pendant une
demi-heure
ici attention
[Musique]
vous allez pas commencer à me dire que
sont des débiles il faut faire attention
il faut juste faire attention de
comparaison moi c'est tout attention
merci bien
les jeunesses fascistes ça te va bien
c'était les mêmes principes en brigadés
la terreur principe d'action vous avez
reconnu avoir agressé le journaliste et
de Louis PNL c'était le 22 février
dernier dans un restaurant du 12e
arrondissement de Paris il s'est exprimé
pour la première fois dans une interview
du magazine américain variety s'est
déclaré stupéfait il espérait des
excuses de votre part mais comme elle ne
viennent pas pour l'instant il a annoncé
son souhait d'un tenter une action en
justice par principe on sait très bien
qu'il a tapé ensemble
il a pas été condamné
mais il a été blanchi très bien
[Applaudissements]
vous souhaitez toujours pas expliquer ce
geste
moi je veux parler de Jeanne Dubarry ok
et vous regrettez ce geste est-ce que
vous lui avez posé la question est-ce
qu'il regrette s'il était là je lui
posais la question posez-lui de
regretter quoi
je préfère pas en parler je ne regrette
pas
je vous ne regrettez pas donc il va
falloir un certain temps pour que ça
excusez-moi j'ai un double appel j'ai
cru que ça avait coupé
à qui vous avez dit allô comme ça non
j'ai cru que ça avait coupé j'étais
dégoûté
en fait
imaginer
une procession d'éponge de douche un
oiseau qui a tenté de s'envoler tant
bien que mal et enfin une énorme star
comment ça qui vous ne le reconnaissez
pas c'est lui le seul l'unique je suis
Bernard qui avait dit le fondateur de
comme j'aime
si même le fondateur de comme j'aime est
ta canne je pense que la quinzaine va
être de toute beauté
[__] c'est long